hi guys my name is grace Helbig if you
did not know I got bored with myself in
the middle of that sentence welcome to
this video
it's a QA I went on my Facebook page I
have a Facebook page and I might use it
to do live events on in the future so
empty promises
I want my Facebook page and ask you guys
for questions and now let's answer them
because that's how this system works if
your entire life was a movie what title
would best fit It's a Wonderful Life
is kidding probably psycho or Gone with
the Wind
I know I shouldn't eat lactose but I do
and it gives me gas my butt creates wind
and it turns all of my friends away Gone
with the Wind just in case you wanted a
full explanation what's your favorite
fantasy creature slush animal slash
character I love the dog from the
neverending story he's just having a
great time and he's helping people he's
large and awkward
that's my god is your liver mourning
house also thoughts on liver mourning as
a name for a spool I'm probably saying
that wrong deeper is it ever ever Moni
elver morning I know I know it's like
nails on the chalkboard to all the Harry
Potter kids out there that are like
right ah those of you that don't know
there's more Harry Potter and there are
American houses that have just been
discovered and you can take a sorting
quiz what house did I get got likes
Quidditch Quidditch pas quoi G is my
house if you want to know for bonus
points my wand is an acacia wood with a
phoenix feather core 13 and 3/4 inches
Oh
that was me using my wand are you happy
with how the live reading a freak week
turned out I loved it so much thank you
for coming to the live reading a
frequent it turned out incredibly
amazing morrow on this youtube channel
will have some BTS video of what it was
like getting ready and on the AT&T
YouTube page will have the full video of
the live reading for those of you that
couldn't come to VidCon and if you want
to read all a freak week in its entirety
because chapter 8 my final chapter went
up on their walk pad page go check it
out all the links for everything will be
down below ow I hate sports what was it
like doing a photo shoot with an alpaca
yesterday Hannah mamrie and I did a
video shoot with an alpaca here's a
little this week it was amazing the
alpaca was absolutely stunning and also
I'm afraid of animals turns out how's
goose
she's doing pretty good how do you feel
about this safe cheeseburger can't
change the gun control laws but we can
put a cheeseburger on a train and a
seatbelt god bless america
what do you miss most about being on
tour I love hotels
I love hotel rooms amenities room
service ads being made lien sheets I
think I just like cleanliness where can
I buy a party time t-shirt oh you've
been buy party time t-shirt as part of
an entire pre-order package for the
dirty thirty movie at four thirty movie
comm we have mentioned to you guys that
it's coming out in select theaters we
don't know exactly what theaters yet
once we know we'll tell you what we
highly highly highly encourage you to
preorder the movie it's a failure mile
at dirty thirty movie calm and there's
all sorts of packages that you can order
I think there's three different tiers of
packages that come with so many bonus
features and things and stuff and
everyone loves stuff would you rather be
a butt or a foot but cuz I love pumpkin
how are you so cute I don't know oh and
that phony oil I'm primarily cute
because of the shirt I'm wearing those
currently introverted shirts are still
available great now I represent
accomplish its grace six if you've any
interest we have one day left with this
campaign on four different colors and I
enjoy them I like things that send a
message what do you watch on Netflix at
the moment i watch bo burnham comedy
special on Netflix um called make happy
and it was true it made me happy I
enjoyed it very much so check that out
if you haven't yet I'm here to provide
you with stuff to do and things to buy
what's your favorite curse word change
what are your thoughts on my dog that
sounds like the equivalent of like a
Dallas Cowboys Cheerleader like it's
just it needs you to think it's cute
it's trying real hard when is the next
book love both Thank You Cameron I don't
have any plans right now for the next
book but I would enjoy if reading a
third book in the future what would you
want a book about a taint coffee table
book that's it is that what I heard okay
well let's go down the vision board are
you going to do any more Frye Diaries
maybe a great saw big look what I did to
show off for you
alright what are we doing we're Skycam
yay and I got talking food but I'm
really excited a little nervous gosh oh
this all for grace oh my god that's
incredible I hope that that wasn't the
last video of you ever shot I hope this
kind of having went well thank you for
wearing and representing the dumb family
that we have here any advice for a
terrified junior in high school if a day
goes by that you don't violently [ __ ]
your pants in front of someone that you
respect total success what's your
favorite pair of sweatpants these guys
like the stepmom of sweatpants
so sassy and trashy and they take real
good care of me do you feel dead inside
yes what is your philosophy of life
we're all gonna die if you could host
either my drunk kitchen or you deserve a
drink which would you choose I think I'd
have to do drunk kitchen game race too
good at the joke's on you deserve a
drink I couldn't live up to those
standards and my drunk kitchen is just
like a playground for debauchery and
that's the only kind of playground I'm
allowed near what do you think is a
major essential for a college dorm room
some sort of system of responsibility so
you can manage your expectations on how
she's your roommate is that's more of an
intangible essential but I think it's
essential nonetheless shower shoes if
you could go with that one body part
what would it be adversely if you could
have an extra body part what would it be
and where I'll go without this extra
bone then I got down here an extra body
part I love just like little butts for
ears so that when someone told you a
secret you just fart in the face
communication is important if you could
trade places with any youtuber for a day
who would you choose and what we could
do I'll probably choose Lindsey Stirling
and I would play violin all day and just
feel what it's like to be a serial also
Lindsey I have a new EP out and
electrical game would you rather have
lunch with your fave celebrity or get
unlimited Target gift cards unlimited
Target gift cards a hundred percent like
Liam Neeson would be fun to sit down at
the Cheesecake Factory with but mama
wants some area rugs if you had to put a
picture of food on a t-shirt which food
would you put alright this
for this QA thank you guys so much for
your questions I hope that these answers
suffice if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because we round fun here and don't
forget that the myriad of things I've
asked you to buy check out the a 10 have
all links down in the description box
below well please go check those things
out if you want if you don't I really
don't give any I would give more [ __ ] to
the hassle but right here in here yeah
what a mom I don't know how do you do
social things alone like go out to
dinner or see a movie by yourself how do
you not just panic and retreat I hate
going out to dinner by myself I hate
sitting alone in public and I have
friends that do it so well I'm still
learning how to do this for myself I
instead like to do solo things in the
comfort of my own home for instance I
have fun